là bà rất là chứ, chúng thật và chính đấu.
Thêm bà rất là là làm điều bắt ngờ
học họ và sánh tạo.
Vì nhận cho quì.
Vì video như họ họ sẽ bảo.
Mình cũng gái vào,
cái gia nhẹ của mình để mình cứ làm vào những khí cổ.
Tì cho chắc bạc, đồ phát.
Học lớt thế được.
Rồi chứ hả nha là làm điều bắt ngờ.
Tìm ra bắt ngờ đây, thì hở sao hán nghĩa.
Là cá trong nâu bộng đi và cá cá khách hàng.
Tìm nất nống như cái xin lâu bàn của những tìm,
mò đàn lo sítik.
Thì có cái câu truyền ở trong người đi.
Đi ngành cái ngài của mình sẽ tìm xin lâu bắt ngờ làm.
Con nhờ, có truyền đến game có cái hàng ngoài mà.
Thì hả nha làm gì làm khi mừng người dạc được.
Nếu là đều có người ta mấy đầy ở ngoài,
lúc đó có nước rất là hoàn trọng.
Rồi thì giọng mà chào quì ăn.
Công đi mà đẹp cho nó muốn lớn thế thì phải thực sự là muốn gàu.
Và chào quý quì nó.
Sao cắt cái lức là.
Công đi này thì có năng ngay lẹ vô.
Cấp bật là cũng đi.
Công muốn ác dụng của nó vào để cho các người...
...cả gái nhem của liên dưới khó cái sự chú đồng hơn.
Và đất cả những ai mà.
Có cái kết thêm qua tốt.
Đi đều phải là giá nhạc mà thừa.
Đi đảo ý chết là bây giờ mà tình thàn.
Để để cho anh nhem mà đặc có đồng lực.
Cảm ơn mệt không kết biệt tốt.
Đó đừng anh không chương trình được chân trời.